so we now move to the second part of
today's in the parliamentary committee
meeting and after we just had the
opportunity for an exchange of views
with four high representative it's now a
pleasure for me to welcome mr. Oliver
Vahey the new Commissioner for
neighborhood and enlargement mr. BAE a
warm welcome colleagues I would like to
give mr. Vahey the floor immediately
just telling you Commissioner that there
are representatives from the different
national parliaments from EU Member
States members of the Foreign Affairs
Committee and also members from the
Parliament's of Norway Montenegro and
bosnia-herzegovina
we have agreed that you will mainly
focus on enlargement policy which is
pretty obvious because that is your
dossier I would like to inform the
colleagues of the national parliaments I
will try to give the floor to as many as
possible I have a list of names and I'm
trying to go through them of course in
this session colleagues will have the
priority who already asked to take the
floor in the first round but weren't
able to I'll try and be as just and as
fair as possible and now without any
further ado mr. behave the floors yours
and the more time you give colleagues
for the discussion the happier they will
travel back to their Member States and
talk in a positive way about the
European Union please thank you chairman
I would try to do my best and cut my
messages to the absolute necessity
chairman honourable members members of
national parliament I welcome the
opportunity to discuss the prospects of
European enlargement to the Western
Balkans soon after taking office this is
one of the first exchanges I have
yesterday I had the opportunity to meet
members of Parliament's of the Western
Balkans and this committee and today a
modern
be to meet the members of our national
parliaments the parliaments of our
Member States national parliaments have
a crucial role in Europe in enlargement
policy enlargement cannot take place
without the consent of the national
parliaments and I do take that very
seriously in mind when I plan the work
ahead of us yesterday we've been talking
about with the colleagues from the
Western Balkans about how we could
create a clear vision for them and for
us when it comes to European perspective
when it comes to our common future we
need to support these countries these
countries are lying in the heart of
Europe supporting the region is very
much in our own self-interest therefore
we all win if our direct neighbourhood
is prosperous stable and secure we all
benefit if the economies in the region
are strong and the level of prosperity
rises way before the accession the same
goes for example for connectivity we
transport energy or digital in a similar
vein the countries of the Western
Balkans have cooperated well with us on
migration and border management but they
need more help to cope with continuing
migration challenges national
parliaments can also provide valuable
advice to Parliament's in the Western
Balkans they can help them to ensure the
proper functioning of democratic
institutions enhance parliamentary
accountability oversight of the exist of
the executive and democratic scrutiny
the best way to leverage progress in the
region which is an integral part of
Europe is through a
credible enlargement process we
therefore need to make sure that this
accession perspective remains credible
for start the reforms all the countries
of the region have to embark must have a
real impact on the ground that means
boosting prosperity creating jobs
improving the quality of life and the
sense of freedom for people in our
partner countries this will only happen
if the pace of reforms is not only
sustained but accelerated honourable
members early next year the Commission
will present suggestions to contribute
to driving the process forward to build
on the Western parking strategy of last
year to strengthen our cooperation and
to render the negotiation process more
effective while also acting on the
concerns raised by some of our member
states the fundamentals of the rule of
law economic development functioning of
democratic institutions and public
administration reform will feature high
on our agenda these are issues which are
right at the heart of the societal
transformation all Western Balkan
countries are undergoing to be ready for
their eventual membership in addition to
the focus on the fundamentals I also
want the process to be more dynamic and
not just focused on opening or closing
chapters we need to identify
opportunities for closer and earlier
integration in areas of joint interest
incentives are absolutely necessary in
that respect
that is why I want to see the region
better integrated into key European
Union policies even before accession for
example the Western Balkans should be
closely associated to the to our Green
Deal our Digital Agenda or our transfer
European networks in transport and
energy the people of the region should
not have to wait until accession to reap
the benefits of
is key policies strong political
engagement is needed on reforms in the
region not for the EU but for the sake
of the citizens of the Western Balkans I
want to see a better political steering
of the accession process and closer
involvement of member states including
at the highest level to support and keep
track of the fundamental reforms needed
and governments in the region need to
take responsibility to be sure the
reform process is inclusive Parliament's
have a key role in this process
not least to be able to adequately
scrutinize the many legislative reform
proposals put before them the European
Union must also prepare for its part to
be ready to take onboard future members
once conditions are met this should not
slow down the accession process in any
way the two processes deepening EU
integration and accession can run in
hand-in-hand the regional cooperation
and good neighborly relations are
essential for progress on the countries
in the European path I would be fully
engaged in this context and will support
all efforts for the resolution of
bilateral disputes for example I will
work with the high representative Joseph
Burrell there were the objective to
bring the baguette Pristina dialogue to
a successful conclusion already next
year honourable members the recent lack
of consensus in the European Council to
open membership talks with Albania and
North Macedonia was a source of great
disappointment for many of us
nevertheless our commitment to their EU
perspective remains unchanged we cannot
be credible geopolitical commission if
we don't get relations with our most
immediate neighbors right and closest
and the Western Balkans are more than
neighbours they are at the heart of
Europe I will continue to defend our
proposal to open accession negotiations
therefore with both countries and and I
cannot stress enough the importance of
taking a positive decision on opening
negotiations well ahead of the Zagreb
summit of next year the creation
presidency therefore will have a crucial
role to play in this respect let me also
add a word on Albania and our support
for the country following the
devastating earthquake of last week we
have immediately launched the civil
protection mechanism and many member
states were on the ground delivering
assistance is shortly after the
catastrophic we are also looking at how
to help beyond emergency needs today at
our first College meeting we have
decided to allocate 15 million euros to
Albania for post disaster aid and we
will also organize a donors conference
for the country and we are looking into
further possibilities to help Albania to
recover from this catastrophic chairman
let me conclude with the remark on the
next multi-annual financial framework
this commission opens a new chapter for
the European Union among the many
changes we are about to witness
none will have a greater impact on our
work than the new MFF for 2021 2027 I
strongly believe that the combination of
a new commission and the new mff should
bring renewed opportunities for coal
closer cooperation with our partners and
also to increase our leverage in the
region thank you very much
anam I'm happy to answer any questions
Thank You Oliver wahey the format is
here that I give the floor and as many
colleagues as possible can ask for
questions and if you say for the first
round that's enough you just indicate ok
we start once again with our guests from
the national parliaments first would be
mr. Ficino from Italy
si si grazie in Gratzer commish REO in a
tournament a press so we're local
commerce REO dato sri balcony she didn't
tally your pension of the Americans of
every age una cosa so opposite Aventa
cuatro an e de la posada de to adore
polyp as AI a Lindo mana del Apache did
I don't know a [ __ ] promise so I'll know
AB Commissario lapadite on know a [ __ ]
promise so equip is a link Luciana
rupiah comes up heavily Kelly
integration or rubella condition the
stability ID cigarettes Adela region
venti Quattro a national unggi so un
cuarto de Circulo
so no not as a degenerate Sione is
annoyed continuum ou are in the air in
the arid in via request on Isola
consequence LOD alimentary frustration
and le public opinion e-reader la spirit
Sione
entirely in a robe he dares pursue a
Larry president national is mo a del
populism Oh Quinn do so la Condamine
okay local commissary or de tama penso
que tu t lo vemos Austin Eric llamó la
proposed care commissary aquifer torture
kept rhymin Cora Delaware teacher dinh
de Gabrielle CC a know they fatty
significative Romano in Black Hawk El
Casino repair appraisal Ultima Union
Adele apparently never see Artie Cong
Albania Macedonian second request own a
sauna parola
mt tolo colleague rules of flight
entitle LT t LOL Commissario Commissario
Perla large amento a passivity knee cosa
pence Adela situational Mediterraneo le
quai local union repaired MF r NL
Mediterranean thank you
European Parliament mr. gala
yeah finding hakama sabzi hominy iron
atom totally exact naturally achievement
than a phenomenally false it's human
food once well hidden even a sign last
woman Zambia Albanian or not Macedonian
item pack heat patata it I'm mr. GAE
this land now son
and last two men were taught that we
hadn't curtains easy for stern valya
ining a critic go I said warden wah and
in the gloom and some bashful in
Albanian understand attack wonderful
eyes doc business for infants physician
president dances ogner I must not
coveted when could the first tenders
packet afternoon and as ayat says
politicians ignite resentment yeah I
think that's momentum on beginning drama
amid not Macedonian and I banyan was not
yet I know that under for all Satsuma
foreigner and Mohammed and Angeles and
fighter some way I wanna [ __ ] hide
caveat Mohammed's my cotton by them bite
with the middle lost all patience tartan
as you conduct us via win
thank you finding me her gala
next from the national parliaments is
madam sanguis from France
Madam President mr. Coony severe enough
Yamazaki need informally radiculopathy
small elegy small sofa parallel see
neutral favor mmm tone francais ml tres
la la cosa a blue key L'Ouverture de
negotiation dadaism soup on de la cosa
we see present an abugida Reforma Avenue
open e ki sabji
aha opposition antiquarian gradually
irreversible and switch our finish areas
in guven also specific modems you
couldn't serve a collective appreciation
of you so may disagree bar on my Pasha
dual opposition of consent so long who
is possible to control a Conde de
Elizabeth on structure hello young
falcon possible evolution do all this
Vivi to control de la camisa doll
evaluation Levon CD D Zeta Conde de y
para la Vega know it will kill Bridget
the Millville Katie booty last man
daniel keep revenue owes do la do la
flock did you PD welcome Delmon Young
will commence ever Lemoine suplementario
movie party calzones holy purely
strategic on my team dentist is small
but with me oh ho could pass through
Antigua strong disapproval merci merci
madam for the Social Democrats in the
European Parliament mr. Sanchez amor
you've agreed president really love and
adhere interior is Alfredo - Keon
Quattro Casillas
courtesy of Allah Allah solace in your
beret
dicen que tiene CAC touring closer
cooperation
kinetochore miss REO Carell and rathian
contour kia steadily faceted Rukia cope
ice candidato
ecomo socio OBC no importante regular
soup on go pour party deuce to the
source ponder said acuerdo
i alguna conversatio granted elders days
sir L Dorsey director Kia a alguna queer
don't rosters sobre como repartee set
importante materia
gracias Thank You mr. Mejia has asked
for pockets of five so we have one final
speaker mr. pisco from Portugal are you
present please thank you Thank You
chairman I had some questions through
mr. Birrell unfortunately I couldn't I
couldn't put to him but I also have a
question about future enlargement don't
you think
it would be more wise to give more time
to the candidates to the present
candidates to firmly assume the European
values they before they become members
and allow me also to layer protects
because all the national parliaments
have been mobilized to came here and I
don't think is correct that we only had
20 minutes to a change viewers read mr.
parelle I hope the next time we had more
time with him thank you okay thank you
I'm not responsible for the timetable of
a high representative but I would like
to say that we appreciate very much
about he even had time to come in his
first week here
and by the way organizing this
conference wasn't that easy because
until two weeks ago I wasn't sure if we
would have a new Commission in place
anyhow and our effort committee played a
crucial role that mr. Vahey got through
in a second round so mr. BAE hey the
floor is yours and speak as long as you
wish because many more colleagues want
to have their questions Thank You mr.
chairman I will try to answer the
questions in a very concise way so that
we can have the maximum number of
questions coming from the floor first on
on the question put by mr. gather on the
coupling well the coupling is I would
say a political product that we see
coming up and down depending on
depending on on the weather basically
but my my point of view is that we need
to look at the countries on the merit we
have made very clear and extensive
requirements to be met by both north
Macedonia and Albania they have met
these conditions so coupling or not
coupling is not an issue the issue is
that they have met these conditions at
same time and this is why we have to
take the decision together because
otherwise we would be unfair to one or
the other if we would not be rewarding
the same level of achievement with the
same reward so my my approach is still
and it's going to stay like this that we
have to open negotiations in March with
both countries but of course I am NOT
deaf
I hear the concerns in relation to
Albania
from some of our member states and I'm
going to act upon that and I'm going to
make sure that I will have the support
of all the Member States otherwise I
will never succeed so I will devote our
most effort to reach out to those member
states if necessary to the national
parliaments as well I have met already
the Foreign Affairs Committee of the
Danish for cutting and I will engage
also with Albania to make ends meet on
the French proposal there are many other
proposals as well on the table as you
know it's not only the French proposal
that we see we see also a major group of
member states who are very unhappy about
the lack of decision in the new European
Council but as I said we need to look
into the concerns I'm happy to to look
at the concerns I will travel to Paris
very quickly I will engage with the
French authorities to understand their
concerns but even the French authorities
are very clear about one thing no one no
one has questioned the European
perspective for these countries it is it
is untouched so we should not we should
not open any discussion about that and
I'm not willing to do that I'm willing
to look into methodology I'm willing to
look into how to better relay the pro
to the national parliaments of the
national governments how we could pool
better our information on the ground and
our how we could share our assessment on
the ground but I'm not willing to engage
into a debate about the European
perspective on the on the increased
budget and what is it it that it could
serve it could serve us for instance to
integrate instantly the whole Western
Balkans into the ten T Network the 10 T
Network is crucial for any economy
building without transport and energy
infrastructure it is not going to be
possible to integrate them then I turned
to the question related to our common
work with the High Representative on
Turkey it goes without saying that the
college acts in a collegial way and of
course with Joseph Borel
we are in close contact in the last in
the first three days of our work I think
I've met him at least five times we are
in constant contact and of course on
Turkey it's not only the neighborhood
policy that is at stake but also major
foreign policy and security policy
issues that are at stake so we are
working hand-in-hand as a very very
strong team finally on the situation in
the in the Mediterranean well I could
dwell on that I think for quite a quite
a couple of minutes but to give you the
gist of our thinking we would like to
bring peace prosperity and stability
also to that region and of course who
are who are willing to cooperate with us
to create a local economy for the local
population and therefore create
stability and who are also willing to
cooperate with us on issues that are of
major concern for us like migration we
would be engaging as much as we can I
could give you one example which is
Morocco I think that Morocco could be
taken as a role model
whole region and we will be we will be
open to have similar level or even
higher level of cooperation with with
other countries let's say Tunisia so our
approach is going to be about reaching
out but also representing our interests
and finding our common interests Thank
You Commissioner Thank You Oliver
second round we start again with our
friends from the national parliaments
mr. clich from Poland please or click
click sorry he's not here ok then mr. as
you Ballas from Lithuania Thank You mr.
chairman
first of all I would like to ask about
our common possible position
successfully resist Russia's constant
attempts to stop some EAP countries from
we're way towards EU and the second
question goes to Belarus don't you think
but our third time reengagement V
Belarus is just another way to help too
mr. Lukashenko dictatorship to survive
thank you thank you for very eery group
re group I have two requests q chicken
ostriches can you agree on one okay
Petrus Elin alright thank you thank you
David
I mean we share a question all right I
mean share a question it's 30 seconds
each okay it's done it's done I mean we
are in a renew group I mean we can do we
can renew lot lots of things Amina in
between Commissioner by Christmas we
might have one less country in Europe
the Larousse might be swallowed by
Russians I mean they are meeting every
day we are sitting here debating general
questions I mean they're about to
integrate Belarus into the Russian
Federation they call it integration I
call it Angeles of 21st century we might
miss this partner we need I mean on the
common borders of the European Union so
what's your take on on its I mean how
much and how long we can simply empty
speak on partnership priorities and lose
from our eyes I mean disappearance of
one independent country Thank You Ellen
do it for 30 seconds
for sure yes me yes let's talk about
more about more about so-called
non-paper the French proposal I think
it's important and I'm ready to hear
what is your understanding about the
methodology and the the real question
are you willing to change the
methodology if your answer is yes how
you can implement it on the Commission
level and then what is the final
understanding about Western Balkans when
it comes to clear possibly future
enlargement thank you Ellen and I would
like to give the floor from a
representative of one of the countries
who wants to join the EU from the
Montenegrin Parliament Nicola rikuo
Chevak where is Montenegro
please sir thank you very much I'll try
to be brief so we are very committed in
investing Balkans especially in
Montenegro to fulfill all of our
obligations on a path of the reforms we
will never of course give up on our
future but please help us Budin
enthusiasm
of the societies of the Western Balkans
because if we do not do so you know that
we are opening space for third countries
that do have their interest to make
influence and penetration in the
countries of the Western Balkans so we
know it very well in in Montenegro
because we had some Russian influence in
in past years my question is we are
mentioning methodology does it mean that
methodology will be trained for the
countries that are already in the
process of Montenegro in seven years now
negotiating and of course Serbia as well
so the methodology will stay the same
for those countries or you don't know
that by far of course for the countries
that will start negotiations I guess in
methodology will be applied thank you
very much thank you sir
Mick Wallace are you still here and then
the next is for the non inscri Hungarian
colleague mr. Ganga she congratulations
for your appointment and thank you for
this opportunity to for exchange three
brief questions one of them as you have
mentioned in your expose the EU
enlargement process has received a blow
few weeks ago and after this veto we
veto we have come to recognize that in
the in the Balkans and in the
neighbourhood of the of the European
Union soft power is exerted by a lot of
countries to express their influence and
to exert their their influence in the
sphere of interest and I was wondering
that while countries such as Russia and
Turkey exert their influence through
cultural means or economic means and
very concrete ideas and projects what
does the European Union have to offer
apart from political slogans to those
countries which are waiting for
accession
my second question is how can the
European Union retain its credibility in
the enlargement process when it is
demanding the respect of democratic
norms when some of its member states
don't keep these norms or don't adhere
to these principles and my third
question is when we are looking at the
instruments that you have as a
commissioner in furthering the
enlargement process what what
instruments do you have from prospective
candidates and prospective member states
to point to the to the important issue
of respecting collective rights of
minorities as you know in the Balkans in
the Ukraine this is a very significant
issue and I think before the enlargement
process is is furthered minority rights
also have to be respected thank you very
much thank you colleague and finally mr.
could sue mas from Greece
seat number 118 I've got a circular
brother or he can I've had a special to
hit bro she can die a metaphoric marrow
stone in quickly nobly Oh does he had a
tilaka caddiebuddy a Socratic odessa's
if ifs it is a lavish inevitable [ __ ] is
he in and abducts a professional talker
on quantity conver canyon get his mesh
cohort india feel actually stuffer or
does this as far as its synaptic steven
every trigger he proportionally it in a
logo any keep acidic see a patellar TDC
after is a decimal test facet to need
unity the ocean tony perfume [ __ ]
interior kiss the Ethel Merman
approximate is more before summer CD
every see II knew he dr. kanta brother
from Tony Parker on the prep nature's
propulsive proto rate that in TDC to the
musical to the cutest Alice's about ie
products II would super headaches Horus
yet eBrush coma say tell if there's a
Mecca tapori para via to this new
geological analysis seen every terrible
show you
Sherri's so second round Oliver yes
thank you very much on on Eastern
Partnership I try to group the questions
first of all on Ukraine and and how we
could advance cooperation and stability
with Ukraine there again I think apart
from the fact that we need to stand by
obviously the territorial integrity of
Ukraine and as long as there is no
progress in the manes process we cannot
loosen any of the sanctions that we have
imposed against Russia we have to also
engage more and be more present in
Ukraine and in any other Eastern
Partnership country who is willing to
engage more with us in as many fields as
possible of course those with a DC FTA
have more room to to to deepen our
relations and we stand ready to do that
but we also stand ready to reach out
when it comes to the building of a
market economy for them and I could
repeat the exact same messages that we
can bring to the Western Balkan that
without a real economy these countries
are always going to be vulnerable and it
is our best interest to improve the
stability of our region that through a
sustainable economic development now on
Belarus our approach is that once we
once we completely pull out from any
cooperation from Belarus we also lose
any leverage that we have we already
have very little leverage in Ukraine
in Belarus we already have just
incremental level of cooperation with
them but we need to be there on the
ground we need to be able to help the
civil society we need to be able to
represent our values because otherwise
we are also the ones who are basically
accepting their turning towards Russia
so when we approach Belarus we also have
to have that in mind on on the French
paper it seems that the French paper is
is a point of reference for for many of
you but as I have said changing the
methodology is one thing questioning the
whole enlargement process is another we
can talk about incremental changes in
the methodology to make it more credible
both to the countries and to our own
Member States but also if we do that we
have to make it more dynamic so my
priority in any revision of the
methodology is going to be that once we
have countries delivering we have to
deliver and it goes without saying
because it is also part of the current
methodology that if we have PACs lining
or backtracking then of course we have
to backtrack also in the in the
negotiations but it's not as I said it's
not only the the French paper that we
have in hand we we also have we also
have other ideas now I got many
questions about soft power and how the
EU would want to increase its leverage
on the Western Balkans this is exactly
why I've been raising the economic
argument the economic drive if you take
the example of the 10t we are an
our companies are the are the biggest
investors in the region they are
receiving foreign influence through
mainly one offs one railway line one
highway one power station but if we come
up with an increased level of
participation in the region and with the
mid term long term planning off for
instance their transport infrastructure
then we will have influence in these
countries then we will be able to fight
back any undue influence from third
countries so we can only have a high leg
leverage if we engage more and that is
the plan I am presenting to you on on
the on the review of the methodology I
got a question also whether this would
apply to those already negotiating the
accession I don't think it is a wise
decision or it would be a wise decision
to move the rules during the game
normally we never do that
so I don't want to do it this time
either this is something of course the
college will have to look at we plan to
have a clear outline of our ideas as
early as January that is in the planning
and I should be able to come back to
this committee very quickly after but
you can rest assured I'm not interested
in slowing any further down on the
country I'm interested in bringing
results and bringing forward enlargement
and finally on the question on the
collective rights of minorities yes in
the region collective rights as such for
minorities is a question not everybody
recognize it as a collective right it is
a question also in the EU because
not all of the Member States recognized
the rights of minorities is collective
however the protection of minorities is
an EU value which I'm here to defend
which I'm here to defend in relation to
any of our neighborhood or be it the
enlargement process if I take the
example of the Roma minority in the
Bacchus this is a crucial issue that we
need to look into and the Roma is a very
specific minority very specific to the
region with very specific needs and very
specific problems that we will need to
address so yes mr. Dean joshee I can I
can agree with you that we have to look
into this and I will look into this
because otherwise long term peace and
stability would be very difficult to
create thank you
we come to our third round the first
speaker for the national parliaments is
mr. cowlings from Latvia yes hello thank
you very much we've talked about a
number of countries that are involved in
each Eastern Partnership but very little
about Georgia Moldova or Ukraine and in
all three cases they do share something
in common not only being former Soviet
states but all three have occupied
territories and do you see this as as a
barrier to their future engagement and
integration into into the European Union
now granted they all have reforms to
deal with but they have a particular
problem that is somewhat unique amongst
candidate countries and in particular I
just wanted to single out Georgia as a
country that probably des had deserved
NATO membership many years ago but it's
still struggling to achieve that and at
the same time should be recognized for
what it's accomplished in terms of
the EU as well thank you thank you for
the European Parliament mr. Bilchik
Vladimir
thank you very much chair and great to
see you commissioner congratulations and
best wishes for your mandate it's good
to have you here on your third working
day in office let me raise a couple of
important issues when it comes to
enlargement
I'm glad you started your speech with
the role of national parliaments and
Parliament's as such but you're very
much aware of what the situation is like
with respect to national parliaments in
the region in the Western Balkans I as a
reporter of this house for Serbia I'm
involved in the inter-parliamentary
dialogue in this country but we've seen
a real breakdown and crisis situations
across the region when it comes to
parliamentary work and democratic
parliamentary culture my question is
what is your plan to help to improve
this we need a robust plan this is not
just about a single visit or a single
message this is about the strategic plan
because when we talk about the rule of
law we need working Parliament's second
issue is communication you've raised the
economic issues but the truth is when
you look at the communication of the EU
in the region it's often selective and
oftentimes you hear more about the role
of Russia then you hear about the role
of the EU we need to change this what is
your plan for this communication and
this communication involving the
stakeholders in the region thank you
thank you the next from our National
parliamentary guests is Jeremy from the
Netherlands so thank you very much for
your information my question would be
actually in relation to Turkey could you
please elaborate elaborate a bit more
about how turkey is in different silos
actually approached one in relation to
the migration deal secondly in relation
to the
accession and thirdly in relation to the
NATO what is actually your comprehensive
approach towards Turkey
thank you very much thank you from the
European Parliament mr. mapreduce forest
oh you know brother though a bit Roberto
I would rather use my mother tongue as
in the Houston area ship we Beverly is
another form of the livin la vida began
druthers in Turkey to barracks animal in
Turkey energy then server day with a
can't family account tribunal de llamada
endorsed studious 1070 to death knee vko
the physical the servitor to the Quixote
saliz's oh yeah Tajima mula bandha bali
up low post Isis and the lava Nestor
this hicimos meeting to clear this tip
with alumina induction a that it gavel
Kynaston ROP head of Tejanos it will
kiev risky de santa gragas toes Pusa
sephora asses was a bidder po-tay-to the
after edema Ultima Posse ora non tomato
PA this case is masculine see dounia's
may appendices
this horace extra body never by de NOC
Yannick reduce metal Guzman of toast is
Horace - after
and finally we go back to your home
country Commissioner mr. Chang Ghazala
from the hungarian national parliament
thank you for floor first of all i would
like to stress that hungary position on
the enlargement policy has much changed
they still consider it as one of the
most important strategic policies of the
EU which contributes effectively to
tackling the current challenge
challenges that you is facing it is more
than evident the EU enlargement police
has come to a standstill however in our
view the insufficiency of enlargement
policy mainly comes from the loss of the
credibility of the process therefore we
are convicted that the problem of the
enlargement process is not related to
the current institutional and legal
framework but to the lack of political
commitment on the part of the member
states hungary does not reject the idea
of reviewing the enlargement process
however this cannot slow down the
enlargement project process and obstruct
progress that these countries deserve
furthermore they emphasize the need of
acceleration of the ongoing accession
negotiations with Serbia and Montenegro
mr. Commissioner how do you see when
could be members of the EU Serbia and
Montenegro thank you and finally I'd
like to give the floor to a colleague
who used to be a member of European
Parliament but now he's returned to
national politics mark thomas marker
welcome back to the European Parliament
hope you're doing well yes thank you
expect on crack needles kneecaps ekata a
clerk of rock veneer Burrell to
maricon the can leave hood on you still
and they have to be tracking of bread in
one acquainted the data governance of
ardent daily and a promoter from
phenomen tail erect and very head
democratic selected democracy that of
the SNC board from the Europe Asia uni
and vaibhava table betreff to corrode
Morrell huzzah - la busca baroque
interest from the world and thing that
were Alain dr. Koon allowed held also
coherency is Susan external ballot and
also in turn ballad metal reward also
soft power come Elena are at the Power
Board all self meet selectively same
internal network a chaos phenom until
home director been the European itself
Matata wardega trail and Hellas is the
arrow pace uni selective before build
better cake and stills variant hood girl
from the revolving better for evolving
from catalyst political and social
leaders in in spaniel and the
selectivity at is Val burgers of Kavala
the selectivity is open an Tao
auto-return larcenous Naboo scope of
Kavala before built the Turks president
aired one verdict of revolving one
verçosa goodness Morita see dr. Ferguson
not revoking from cattle answer
political and social leaders in in
spaniel and Don vent ik Rapace burgers
for what you wrong director outlet and
overall
verdict world and the line to started
internet Hobart think about odor the old
and if Roy de bazan advance clinks well
in turn as in the restaurant avail Thank
You Val mark and the next and then we
conclude this round is also a former
colleague from the European Parliament
who's going to Spain to do politics mr.
Jimenez better I'll see Gary Gary hablar
por por illusion
boy boy have Lorraine
en espanol 1 ok dia decirle al
parlamentary ok me oppressor Dido que en
españa no in England no Avedon in guna
viola Sein derecho ho mano y si la vida
acido precisamente por por la persona
que tener la cárcel porque el tribunal
super demo day Tanya
Lisa condenado poor Sadie Seon con la
cual poor dad un golpe de todo por
guerre Ayer por la fuerza you know
defendi endo en un parlamento Komoda
Briand hacer el parlamento de pena
porque las navas dannion sobre la edad
Espanyol @ en el pueblo spanien
colloquial no se puede hacer por la
fuerza por eso es tan IE por lo tanto
que rodea Claro que en españa no I knew
guna falta de Libertad solo es el lo que
onda Corrado yep on Yahoo pies
democrático Elan young europaea tiene
griffin de españa in upon yourself en de
la derecha human o al igual que cela
feeling el onomatopoeia c fo political
attempt ratios pour de un golpe estado
lo vienen hecho en un parlamento al
igual que el parlamento doppio place 8 r
en la calle y lo viren defended on el
sitio de la debris on defended the
floors yours commissioner thank you very
much
first on the on the question related to
Georgia modeling and Ukraine and whether
the the problems they have with Russia
including an occupation of their
territory would be any obstacle to
getting closer to the EU I think not
we have already proven this and we will
continue to prove that the first the
first element is of course the DC FTA it
is clear that by the possibility of
adopting 70% more or less of the whole
EU law body they can bring themselves
basically in every aspect of life as
close as they wish to the EU will
continue to help them to do that and not
only that but if I look at the the free
trade part of these agreements there are
still vast opportunities in front of
these states to come closer and get more
integrated into the EU at the level of
everyday life but as I said if they have
if they have other areas additional
areas where they would like to cooperate
with us more we are more than happy to
do that if I look at Ukraine I would
also find it really interesting if we
could link them much closer in terms of
connectivity be it the digital
infrastructure be the energy
infrastructure or the or the transport
infrastructure so there's quite a bit we
can do and there's quite a bit they
would I think be ready to do so I do not
see any obstacle because of of the
occupied territories that they that they
couldn't engage with us on the contrary
we have to engage with them even more
given that they are under pressure from
on the on the role of the national
parliaments this is this is a very
interesting this is a very interesting
topic we have discussed yesterday with
the representatives of the national
parliaments from the Western Balkans and
their the message is very clear and very
loud that we need everybody to do
politics in the national parliaments we
want everybody to get back to the
national parliaments and do the politics
there I will encourage everybody to get
back to the national parliament and do
work there otherwise otherwise these
countries will never be able to make us
believe that they are able to
participate in the European Union as
members we need also a common
understanding or at least a common
national minimum when it comes to EU
integration so at least they should be
able to set aside their national
differences and agree on issues related
to their integration and their
membership in the EU I will encourage
certainly all members of the of the
national parliaments to do so but I
alone I will never be able to to achieve
this at the my hearing in this committee
I have asked the help of this committee
and I will continue to ask for that help
parliamentarians are peculiar people
they they tend to listen to each other
rather more than to anybody else so I I
think that members of this house members
of the European Parliament are best
place to explain why why the national
parliaments are so crucial in the whole
of the enlargement process and I will
ask and help with my work of course all
any peace who are ready and who are
willing to engage even more with the
national parliaments in the Western
Balkans
there we have quite a lot to do and the
quite and quite a lot to achieve as well
now on the communication in the Western
Balkans
I don't think it it goes without saying
that our presence in the in the in the
Western Balkans when it comes to public
relations is not the best and to put it
to put it mildly
and we will have to work on that on the
other hand if I look at the the facts
and figures what I see is that still it
is the European Union and its member
states who are doing the most in this
region and for this region so we need we
need to look into why in terms of public
relations we are so poor we are so
poorly managed there and I will have to
I will have to really come up with a
plan on this one idea could be something
alike what we are doing in Ukraine with
the programme of EU for you so to really
approach the people and explain to the
people what is it that we do but there's
there's one other one other aspect of
substance which is that I find that our
actions are divided up into too many
little pieces instead of trying to
concentrate to bigger projects to bigger
ideas with bigger impact which will make
it more visible so these are the two
strategies I'm considering but as part
of the of the of the I wouldn't say
revisiting of the enlargement process
but our common thinking on the
enlargement process this is also going
to be a very important element on Turkey
our approach to Turkey I think is very
clear we have fundamental problems in
our relationship we have a problem when
it comes to the legal drilling around
Cyprus the council the Foreign Affairs
Council was very clear
it has introduced the possibility of
sanctions the reopening council was also
very clear and there is no change in
that and we will have to continue until
they give up the drilling activity
around Cyprus we have also
an issue in relation to the accession
negotiations where we have been raising
over and over again our concerns
relating to the front fundamental
freedom freedom of the press the the the
jailing of of journalists or other areas
on crawling back on the rule of law
these concerns remain valid and we will
have to address these concerns as long
as Turkey considers itself to be an
accession country on the other hand
Turkey is the second biggest NATO ally
that is also affect and on the other
hand we also have to cooperate with them
on migration so we need to have a full
reflection a full review of our
relationship with Turkey it will have to
be done in this house and it will have
to be done and I think at the European
Council and it will have to be done also
in the Commission we need to have a
strategic approach towards our relations
and we need to see also our weaknesses
but also our strengths on on Serbia and
Montenegro how to accelerate well this
is the plan I present it to you I I
think the best way of accelerating is by
motivating them to get closer to us as
quickly as possible because if I take
the example of of creating a market
economy it is only through debt that we
can explain why is it important to have
a proper functioning rule of law
democracy freedom of the press because
this belongs also to the business
environment without which our investors
would not risk their money so we need to
create hand-in-hand a market economy
based on the rule of law that works for
us and it works for them and this will
bring about
a much speedier catch up with our region
Chairman I think I'm finished with the
questions yes again it will be the final
round and it will only be composed of
members from the national parliaments
but before I give the floor to the next
speaker Commissioner I wanted to
underline one point regarding the
Turkish drilling activities and Cypriot
territorial waters we had a debate in
the European Parliament and I remember
this debate was that we welcome that the
council has adopted a framework for
restrictive measures against Turkey but
we now expect the sanctions to be
implemented we need travel bans and
asset freezes for individuals who are
responsible for this severe violation of
international law only then we can be
taken seriously as a European Union so a
final round first we have mr. petroselli
from Italy he's not here okay mr. zhabin
yev from poland please okay thank you
Thank You mr. chairman Commissioner you
have just indicated that way a failure
to start the accession process in the
West in the Western Balkans is going
hand-in-hand with a failure to establish
good channels of social communications
and public relations to explain the
situation to be to the local public
don't you believe that it would be
feasible or even reasonable to outline
the timetable for the future accession
process just to make it more encouraging
for these two countries that this
process wouldn't last decades but rather
years thank you
Thank You colleagues could you please
continue to individual conversations
outside the room I'm referring to my
German comrades Cowboys combined so the
next is from the Netherlands mr.
Dietrich Thank You mr. chairman I
assumed the United Kingdom will most
likely not be an EU member state anymore
but of course it will still still be a
neighboring country to the EU mr.
commissioner let's look beyond brexit
and let's say take five years time what
do you think are the most important
elements of collaboration between the EU
and the United Kingdom thank you thank
you
madam juda who's available
micro para hacerlo presidency la camisa
Mexico leg dijo to double importance de
política de vecinos Mediterraneo pata
nahi oriental ya la política de la
resume Angelou you ope Balkan see donto
some primordial pedeu vital le
controversy Donahoe Suman Horus evil
Albania homicide wanna do no te Moana
doliveira City DCJ doin duplication ah
mama sur la camisa pouvez-vous new fave
Appa devote analyse your articulation
Angela política stereo delay on a la
política de la Griezmann nauseam among
an septum oh darn a la declaration final
de la co-presidents de la conférence
entitlement a la pêche a la paz de se
Cellini Kelly possesses de deseo Malaga
fermenter no delay no hope and wattle a
doper porcelain Fox symmetry element
c'mon conserve evil yang entre política
de la misma reformed a functioning
internal Union merci Madame
mr. Dimmit rescue from romania reveal a
vu+ Keystone premier margin Rabia sabaki
leave our opinions of Lama Davi ask
Anton encounter a situation political
maneuver mo de Maya
Sandow a doozy mo on Ibaka partnership
de Sousa blood necessity proposal except
mp2 la France the Reebok Denver egg la
Vida process used in negotiation only
the politic the lineage is ma la técnica
speedo map mum P suntan train your Paris
pecked on a regular
the kapa haka Sapodilla criteria the
compression are a pretty processes the
negotiation the chakra Peter C Illya
besoin de Bock de novo reg'lar okay
remember the man deceive Omaima I was
obviously distraught sulla issues are
they any disability among pro
preconception since Sajid about the
Terramax Sapodilla directly strict avec
des terres gradient grumbles on anybody
pay double count the rest double bond
signal with a bit processors 160 below
Amanda thank you and just information
for you we will have Maya Sandow in the
Foreign Affairs Committee of the
European Parliament I guess next week in
January
we've invited her to inform us about the
state of play in Moldova next second
last on my list is from the Czech
Republic mr. Benishek committee which
totally put positive totally uses new
velocity Oh Shazam is happening
economist emic perspective of protege
Putin profit or victory ever obscure
where ago submarine a grenade with VD
misogyny of zhamuhe and obscure a beach
to the me and eject Oh Samia be ho the
pony or Negroni Nia who shall be Slava
Arouca massage Ahana there is a cruise
ship who could make obscene a Samana
bulk and stability to trackball
consciousness and stability to the Arabs
near the abyss tell the man whom
craniotomy who new partners no hurt
Arabella who she said she know Alaric
represent and Cheska Republic the Rasta
loser oops at the satellite Evo new
partners we be sexual sabotage delay
plan with Whitney me akiza Sydney she's
mean if she's to prove a philosophy
protege oti Joba simultaneous Napoles
Cazadores Nanoha
Syd was a truck weena be not leave is a
mystic j2me concrete notices dolly be
dose Lenovo's upon which a seditious me
a kiss - PO ordinary hone your partner's
to be the quay
and finally mr. me loot Anjou Kennewick
from the Montenegrin assembly joining
the masses are calling us to meet Alamo
bush noses Agra team Bama he rest on its
Hema Doogie Parliament
don't see mr. Nagori Pazhani some
opposite you know Democratic Front you
traced some pretty small sessio
perspectiva percutaneous up an oak
bokken in a shallow swaram of this Rama
the podium is not as mission next
Eastman off to also due November to the
logic we applaud Rio preceding McCrone
major teams are in the South team of the
enemy's limos we birthday at all or no
protein miss Mott Ramada at all
dobro is Rosberg are such a privy
gradually Oct neck a benefit or
protester pre-katrina doses who said OB
le strike away Eric rajala near simile
McAfee caristi carissima
Aprilia coup de pasto in patan v so
compressed amico zania luggage no sanas
open on volcanoes poster develops
chemistry the says ma is major said yet
j-integral
Moulton a the Sukanya Granite's a bio
entity Vimala Schengen burrow
interesante Dalek
chatter vo gravity it's a new burrow in
bosnia-herzegovina
the Supra QJ toe in ctv steamed me mr.
emo
the tentative approach rarity Chuck you
chronic Granite's physics is melodrama
Japan agua con acaba karim the port a
member of standard is medula's not an
LGBT problema de soto karate weakest
integration whoever of school near erode
know the mr. Nagori
very modest integrity mo dance come now
o Dinko premier alan a more modest
poster image abroad knows yo bruiser mo
granite su is Madonna's in a premier
bosnia-herzegovina
the kuan-yin CEO Shino no more Musa Dagh
sobre la la la la puno and just picking
on what you said I was in Belgrade
Monday and Tuesday and like many of us
who traveled to the Western Balkans the
first integration step which we would
all welcome is to abolish for roaming
charges and that's it's it's incredible
that you cross the border and all of a
sudden you're a completely different
world of mobile technology so bringing
down borders in any regard is always
helpful in the Western Balkans
colleagues I think I have covered all of
your requests at least it was a long
long list and we have a final round with
the Commissioner Oliver thank you I had
two questions on a timetable fully for
enlargement this is a tricky question of
course one would jump on it and say yes
2025 but I think we have been there it's
not a question of of picking and
choosing dates and then having to change
it it's setting up a process that will
actually bring enlargement to these
countries so I'm responsible for this
five years and my plan is that at the
end of this five-year term we should
have at least one country ready to join
the European Union
this is what I can tell you in terms of
timetable and this is what I can pledge
but I'm happy to do that on on the
question whether enlargement and
deepening our conditional on one another
I don't think so I think that
enlargement is possible without a major
institutional overhaul of course if we
can agree on an institutional reform so
much the better
but it's not a condition per se to have
full institutional reform in the
European Union before enlargement can
take place the European Union should be
able to work with 28 member states again
on on the question whether the mini
Schengen is a good idea any regional
cooperation before accession between the
Western Balkan countries is welcomed and
I welcome the mini Schengen but there is
one condition
on my side which is it has to be
inclusive everybody should be able to
join it everybody in the Western Balkans
otherwise I can only welcome it
it makes the borders very easy to cross
it helps trade it helps people to people
contacts so it can really bring about
benefits and I and I welcome it but
please make sure that anybody who is
interested can join at any moment from
your region on Moldova and in the
situation in Moldova we are looking very
closely at the situation in Moldova we
see that there is there is now a
political situation which is hard to
predict at least midterm but our line
has not changed we will cooperate with
the Moldovan government as long as they
are delivering on the reforms and we
will continue to help financially
institutionally the reforms but the
reforms have to be done otherwise we
will have to again come up with a
suspension of the financing or other
measures so we need we need Moldova to
stay on track and we are ready to
everything to keep model on contract on
on whether enlargement for Moldova is
foreseen for the time being I see is
very difficult to to come up with an
enlargement perspective but what I know
and what I have already said is that the
DC FTA provides still major room for
improvement in our relations and once we
have implemented the DC FTA and we have
also extinguished all the potential
other areas of cooperation of course
this question can come up and any
European state can apply for membership
but that is a different process
currently we are not there on the the
Eastern Partnership as such and our
future plans we are in the middle of a
reflection period so it is very
difficult to tell you what new ideas we
are going to be bringing about but what
I can already tell you is is bringing
them closer in any areas where where
they see a possibility to cooperate
deeper and stronger with us is going to
be part of that strategy but it's too
early to tell what other new elements
you can expect from us we are now just
about to finish the public consultation
and we will then reflect internally and
we will also reach out of course to
those countries and also to our member
states before we we come up with our
proposals and finally I I left I think
the the the chocolate at the end as they
say the UK question yes we could I mean
it's a joke so don't take it seriously
we could establish a Western partnership
for for the UK if they wish so of course
with some conditions
but honestly we will have to see what
the UK would want to see with us in
terms of relationship but we have we
have somebody else dealing with this and
I would be happy to take it over from
him once he has established the future
relations and I will be happy to work on
that if I get the assignment but
currently my previous Commissioner whom
I love to work for Michel Barnier
this is responsible for that so you
should ask him about this but the least
we need is is is a fully free trade
agreement to say the least but I hope
it's going to be it's going to be more
but Nisha barney is much better place
than I am to explain this to you thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues before you'll jump up let me
briefly conclude this meeting first of
all I would like to thank Commissioner
Vahey for spending so much time with us
answering all our questions and what I
noticed is in a short period of time a
lot of issues are very familiar to you
already
and you've dug in deeply into the
regions and the countries you're dealing
we have so once again good luck for your
political work here in Brussels I would
like to thank the unit for relations
with national parliaments for the
excellent support and organizing this
meeting and I would like to express my
gratitude to you the colleagues from the
national parliaments with your
co-operators that you came to Brussels
today and that you shared your insights
with us I believe these exchanges are
very useful and we would like to
continue this format if you agree I look
forward to our next encounter in the
context of the inter-parliamentary
conference for the CF s P and C SDP in
Zagreb from the 2nd to the 4th of March
Mirel Kovich the chairman of the Foreign
Affairs Committee of the Croatian
Parliament is here we will now discuss
the program which we are organizing for
you so have a wonderful day and evening
in Brussels safe trip back home and see
you latest in March in Zagreb thank you
the meeting is closed